Hallo und willkommen zum zweiten Vortrag über
Denkerinnen in Antike und
Mittelalter und Peter Adamson. Wir werden heute
über die Ansichten von Platon
und Aristoteles sprechen, was sie über Frauen zu sagen hatten
und ob sie dachten, dass
Frauen jetzt philosophieren könnten  Ich wäre
die erste Person, die zugibt, dass weder
Spieler noch Aristoteles eine Frau waren, und
Sie fragen sich vielleicht, ob es in dieser Vortragsreihe
um Denkerinnen in der Antike geht. Im
Mittelalter waren sie in der Antike Plato
und Aristoteles, aber angesichts dessen, dass sie keine
Denkerinnen sind  warum werde ich
heute über sie sprechen und die Antwort
ist, dass ich generell in dieser ganzen
Vortragsreihe nicht nur
über die Denkerinnen sprechen möchte, das ist hauptsächlich das,
was ich tun möchte, sondern ich möchte auch
ein wenig sprechen  etwas über den Kontext, in
dem sie lebten, schrieben und dachten, und
aus diesem Grund müssen wir oft
einen Blick darauf werfen, was männliche Autoren
und männliche Denker
in denselben Zeiträumen, also zum Beispiel, über Frauen sagten
Wenn wir zum Mittelalter kommen,
werden wir uns unter anderem
mit dieser Art laufender Debatte
befassen, die das gesamte Mittelalter zwischen frauenfeindlichen Autoren andauerte, die
Argumente gegen Frauen vorbrachten, also wer sagen würde,
dass sie es waren  bösartig und dumm und nicht
vertrauenswürdig und andere Angebote, von
denen einige Frauen waren, von denen einige
Männer waren, die sich für Frauen und
ihre Tugend, ihre Intelligenz, ihr
Vertrauen in sie aussprachen, und wie wir
jetzt sehen, geht diese Debatte in gewisser Weise den ganzen
Weg  Zurück zur klassischen Antike heute Im
Allgemeinen waren die Meinungen der Menschen über Frauen in der
klassischen Antike nicht das,
was wir feministisch nennen würden, und das ist
milde ausgedrückt, Sie könnten sehen, wenn Sie
sich über die Behandlung von Frauen
im antiken Griechenland lesen, dass Sie vielleicht sogar die
antike Behandlung sehen  von Frauen verglichen mit
der Behandlung von Frauen heute in sehr
strengen antifeministischen Gesellschaften, wie zum Beispiel
unter den Taliban oder in Saudi-Arabien, und
das ist ziemlich richtig, meine ich damit
jeden Tag mit den Taliban vor Ort Kontakt aufnehmen wollen
Sicherlich war die
Situation der Frauen zumindest in manchen
alten Gesellschaften sehr schlecht ich meine
es
war sehr schlecht es variiert ein bisschen so zum
Beispiel in Sparta durften Frauen
aus dem raus
mehr als in
Athen, aber in Athen,
was für uns jetzt natürlich sehr wichtig ist,
weil wir über Platon und Aristoteles sprechen werden, die
beide in Athen lebten, war
der Umgang mit Frauen
sehr hoch  Schlecht und insbesondere für
aristokratische Frauen war die Art von Frauen
, die zu Platons und
Aristoteles eigenen Familien gehört hätten, so, dass
ihnen effektiv angenommen wurde, dass sie
nur die Rolle hatten, im Haus zu bleiben
und sich um die Kinder zu
kümmern, sich um die Sklaven zu kümmern und  Herz
würde mir in manchen Fällen sogar weh tun,
kaum vor die Tür zu gehen, weil von ihnen
erwartet würde, dass sie Diener schicken, um die Einkäufe zu erledigen,
sie waren irgendwie von der
breiteren Gesellschaft abgeschieden  Wenn wir über die
athenische Demokratie sprechen, sprechen wir nicht
über Frauen, die an dieser Demokratie
teilnehmen, sondern wir sprechen nur über männliche
Bürger, damit die Sklaven ausgeschlossen würden
und Frauen ausgeschlossen würden. Jetzt gibt es
ein Zitat, das ich vorlesen werde  Sie,
was wir zusammenfassen, das ist von
dem großen griechischen Redner
Demosthenes,
der sagte, wir haben Kurtisanen zu unserem
Vergnügen,
klobige Linien für die Anforderungen des
Körpers und Ehefrauen für Baris rechtmäßige Kinder
und kümmern uns treu um das Haus, so
dass es ziemlich genau zusammenfasst  hoch, es ist ein Zitat,
wenn Sie oft darüber sprechen,
wenn sie Nationen zur Gesellschaft machen, und
dies ist eine wichtige Sache, die Sie im
Hinterkopf behalten sollten, wenn wir beginnen, uns mit Plato und
Aristoteles zu befassen. Was wir also sehen werden, ist
dieser Platon  stellt im Grunde diese
alte und bevorzugte fenianische Sichtweise von Frauen in Frage,
und was ihre Kapazität auf
unserer Ebene sein wird, nimmt Aristoteles nicht
an, dass dies die Rolle ist, die
Frauen in unserem Leben spielen, und er versucht es nicht
Art des Umkippens, dass es im Allgemeinen
kein sehr revolutionärer
Denker ist, dass er normalerweise nicht versucht,
die Art der Intuition der Menschen über das
politische Leben sehr unberechenbar zu revidieren,
wie es Plato in seiner Republik tut
, aber wie wir gleich sehen werden,
gibt es  eigentlich viel Material in
Plato zu teilen, dass er nicht dachte,
dass Frauen Männern gleichgestellt seien, im
Gegenteil, er dachte, dass Frauen
Männern unterlegen seien, und eine interessante Sache
über Pharoah ist, dass dies sogar in der
Passage sehr berühmter Passagen
der Fall ist  the Republic In genau der Passage,
in der er argumentiert, dass Frauen im Grunde
alles tun können, was Männer können, und sogar
Philosophen sein können und sogar dazu beitragen können, die
perfekte Gesellschaft einer perfekten Stadt zu regieren
,
erinnert er uns immer noch daran, dass Frauen minderwertig sind  gegenüber Männern
in der allgemeinen Meinung der Menschen, also haben wir
hier eine Art sehr revolutionäre, in
gewissem Sinne feministische Diskussion, die
es immer noch
als selbstverständlich ansieht, dass Männer besser sind als Frauen  Eine
Folge davon, die Sie in
vielen antiken Literaturen sehen, ist, dass Sie, wenn
Sie darüber nachdenken, wie die perfekte
Frau ist, und sie mit dem
perfekten Mann vergleichen, nicht
über die gleiche Art von Perfektion sprechen und
hier haben  ein Verstand weniger politische
Realitäten oder politische Theorien als vielmehr
ethische Theorien. Wenn wir also
über Tugend sprechen, wie eine tugendhafte
Frau im Gegensatz dazu, wie ein tugendhafter
Mann ist, dann werden Sie am Ende
mit einer anderen Darstellung davon enden  Ihre
relevanten Tugenden haben jetzt normalerweise Männer im Sinn, wenn das
antike Ephesus über Tugend spricht.
Ich denke, es
wäre fair zu sagen, dass
Philosophen des Altertums und des Mittelalters normalerweise Männer
im Sinn haben, wenn sie über Menschen sprechen,
also wenn sie über die
Fähigkeiten sprechen  eines Menschen oder sie
sprechen einfach über Menschen in irgendeinem Kontext,
ihre Standardannahme ist, dass ich
über Männer und Frauen spreche, dann sind sie eine Art
Sonderfall, da wir sehen werden, dass
es etwas Unterstützung gibt  osed sagen
Grundlage dafür in Aristoteles, also wenn sie
an weibliche Tugend denken, würden sie
das als eine Art
separates Thema von Tugend denken
wie zum Beispiel die
Tugend des Mutes, die
viel mit dem Verhalten im Krieg zu tun haben wird, wie
Sie damit umgehen,
ich meine, es ist eine Gefahr für Ihr Leben und so
weiter, und immer wieder würde man einfach
annehmen, dass dies eine Tugend ist, die nur
relevant ist  für Männer andere Tugenden, obwohl
dies weniger offensichtlich ist, denke ich, dass der
Punkt immer noch auf etwas wie Gerechtigkeit zutrifft,
die die Tugend ist, um die
es in Platons Republik geht. Jemand wie
Eric dachte, es würde wahrscheinlich annehmen,
dass Gerechtigkeit eine Tugend ist,
die hauptsächlich von Männern ausgeübt wird weil  es
werden zum Beispiel Männer oder Richter
vor Gericht sein, die eine
gegebene Situation gerecht bewerten müssen,
also schauen wir uns diese Passage an, die eine
Passage von Plato ist, und wir wissen es  Wir können
tatsächlich einen Ausdruck dieser Idee sehen,
dass sich die Tugend der Frau
von der des Mannes unterscheiden wird, also ist der
Kontext hier, dass es in Platons
Meno einen Dialog gab, in dem Sokrates
mit mir nein sprach und Sokrates
mich nun bat, zu erklären, welche Tugend  ist, und wir
wissen, antwortet mit einer Art Liste
verschiedener Arten von Tugend und sagt
, die Tugend einer Frau, wenn Sie wissen wollen,
das kann auch leicht beschrieben werden, ihre
Pflicht ist es, ihr Haus zu ordnen und zu halten,
was drinnen ist, und ihrem Ehemann in jedem
Alter zu gehorchen  Jeder Zustand des Lebens, ob jung oder alt,
männlich oder weiblich, oder drei, hat eine
andere Tugend. Es gibt viele
Tugenden von uns, und es gibt keinen Mangel an
Definitionen dafür, denn Tugend hängt von den
Handlungen und dem Alter eines jeden von uns ab, in allem
, was wir tun und tun  Dasselbe gilt für
Vize Sokrates, also sagt Meno
hier ausdrücklich, dass die Tugend von
Männern und die Tugend von Frauen unterschiedlich sind.
Die spezifische Tugend wird oft
mit Frauen in Verbindung gebracht, die er eingefroren sah, oder mit Mäßigkeit bei
Männern  Ich habe das in der
Vorlesung eigentlich erwähnt, weil es
in einigen dieser Texte von
pythagoreischen Frauen hervorgehoben wird, über die wir gesprochen haben,
und was hier niemand sagt,
fällt eigentlich auf ihre Art von allgemeiner
Theorie der Tugend, die von seinem
Lehrer, dem berühmten Rhetoriker
, stammte, der ähnlich sagte  Nun, es gibt nicht nur
eine Sache, bei der
es verschiedene Tugenden oder
verschiedene Arten von Menschen geben wird, und selbst sie
würden bereit sein zu sagen, dass es solche
Tugenden oder Kurse gibt, also könnte die Tugend eines
Pferdes sein, ein starkes Wesen zu sein  tapfer
im Kampf und so weiter, also kann man nicht
allgemein sagen, was Tugend ist, man kann
einfach eine Art Liste geben, und tatsächlich,
was Sokrates in dieser
Passage tut, ist, diese Annahme von Minos in Frage zu stellen,
und er sagt gut, was ich bin
suchen hier ist keine liste verschiedener
arten von tugend vielleicht kannst du mir
das sagen vielleicht kannst du nicht ich bin was ich nicht
wissen will ist was die definition von
tugend an sich ist und wir haben hier ein wort das
w  Ord Tugend a High-Tech auf Griechisch
bedeutet so sicher etwas Spezifisches und
etwas Vereinheitlichtes. Es ist erwähnenswert, dass
Sokrates in keiner Weise in Frage stellt,
was Meno über Frauen erschreckt, sodass
beide es einfach als
selbstverständlich ansehen, dass die Tugend der Frauen ist
zu hause bleiben maßvoll sein den
haushalt führen und wenn es auffällt dem ehemann gehorchen
oder was anderes kommt und
das wird auch
Aristoteles finden sagen also eigentlich mache
ich jetzt was es ist etwas
überraschend weil Aristoteles
näher kommt  zu einer Anhörung zu diesen
griechischen Standardvorstellungen über Frauen, die Plato kennt,
weil Platon so
revolutionär ist, werde ich eigentlich
zuerst über Aristoteles sprechen und dann
über Platon, also lassen Sie sich davon nicht verwirren,
ich habe keine Art  der radikalen neuen
historischen These, dass Aristoteles arbeitete,
bevor er geflitzt ist, da Sie wahrscheinlich wissen, dass
sie zur gleichen Zeit lebten, spielte es
eigentlich Harris alle als Lehrer, also waren sie
Teil der größten Fou  r
Generation Lehrer Schüler angekettet in der
Geschichte Sokrates war der Lehrer von
Platon Plato Plato war der Lehrer von
Aristoteles und Aristoteles war der Lehrer
Richtig schlagen, dass, wenn Sie können, aber der
Grund, warum ich zuerst über Aerosol spreche
, obwohl Fleischunschuld nach
Play-Doh kommt
Er ist offensichtlich jünger als Play-Doh,
wie ich schon sagte, dass er näher an einer Anhörung
zu Standard-Alten und Besonderen ist. Vielleicht,
wenn er sich eine Vorstellung davon macht, wie eine Frau
jetzt sein kann, gibt es verschiedene
Kontexte, in denen Aerosol über Frauen spricht,
der offensichtlichste Kontext  und die Art von
Kontext, an die die Leute immer zuerst denken,
wenn sie über Frauen sprechen, ist das, was er
in seiner praktischen Philosophie sagt,
womit ich Ethik und Politik meine,
tatsächlich definiert Aristoteles praktische
Philosophie als ein Gebiet mit drei nicht zwei
Hauptbereichen, also hätten Sie FX
die auf das Individuum gerichtet ist, haben Sie die
sogenannte Ökonomie, wie ich letztes
Mal erwähnt habe, ist auf das Studium des
Haushalts gerichtet, und Sie haben Politik w  Ob
das Studium des Staates oder der Polis
größer ist, der Stadtstaat, er hat kein
Werk über Wirtschaft geschrieben, also haben
wir Ethik und Politik. In beiden
Fällen spricht er über Frauen, sozusagen nebenbei,
die engagierteste Diskussion  ist
im ersten Buch der Politik zu finden, also
wollte ich natürlich nicht darüber sprechen
, aber zuerst wollte
ich Ihnen etwas Kontext aus einem Ergebnis
wissenschaftlicher Arbeiten geben, weil dies eine andere
Stelle ist, an der er über Frauen spricht oder
vielleicht  Eigentlich sollten wir nicht Frauen sagen, sondern Frauen,
denn diese beiden
sind zoologische Werke, deren
Studien über Tiere mehrere
Abhandlungen über Tiere geschrieben haben, und darin
interessiert er sich offensichtlich sehr für
Fortpflanzung, also brachte er tatsächlich
ein ganzes Werk mit dem Titel When the
Generation auf den Markt  von Tieren, wie Tiere
entstehen und sich vermehren, und im Allgemeinen
interessiert er sich sehr für die Beziehung
zwischen Mann und Frau bei einer
ganzen Reihe von Tierarten und
daher, wo  Wenn er darüber spricht, ist es
nicht unbedingt notwendig, tatsächlich
denkt er wahrscheinlich nicht hauptsächlich an
menschliche Frauen, aber was er
in einem zoologischen Werk sagen wird, soll er
vermutlich
sowohl auf menschliche Frauen als auch auf
nichtmenschliche weibliche Tiere anwenden, damit wir es können
Nehmen Sie das, was er hier sagt, und wenden Sie es
auf den menschlichen Fall an, und eine Frage, die
wir hier stellen müssen, ist, ob die
zoologischen Abhandlungen und das, was er
in den zoologischen Abhandlungen über das Weibchen sagt,
in irgendeiner Weise rechtfertigen oder
die Begründung dafür sind was er ist  Was Sie
über Frauen in der Ethik und der
Politik sagen würden, was Sie
nach modernen Maßstäben sehen werden, würde als
sehr frauenfeindlich angesehen werden,
also sind diese Einstellungen gegenüber Frauen, wie
ich bereits angedeutet habe, im Grunde,
dass Frauen Männern eindeutig unterlegen sind
und  Sie haben eine sehr spezifische Rolle
in der Gesellschaft, die darin besteht, zu Hause zu bleiben und
sich um die Kinder zu kümmern, sich um den
Haushalt zu kümmern, also ist dies die Art
von Frauen, die barfuß und schwanger in der Küche sind
Das, was er sagt, ist, oh
Allah, gut, es gibt verschiedene Arten von
Kot, die er in der
Zoologie vorbringt, und das offensichtlichste ist, dass
Frauen die Materie für einen
Nachwuchs liefern, während Männer die Form liefern,
also sagt er das zum Beispiel in
Generationen  von unseren Tieren, aber für
Kapitelfrauen okay, also was bedeutet das
gut hier, wir müssen ein bisschen darüber wissen,
was Aristoteles darüber denkt,
dass Form wichtig ist, wir müssen nicht wissen, dass das
Schloss ein Standardbeispiel sein könnte
, könnte einen Mann nehmen -  Gemachtes Artefakt Wir befinden uns hier
auf sexistischem Terrain Aristoteles
Sinne war nur ein von Menschenhand geschaffenes und nicht einmal
gemachtes. Nehmen wir also ein von Menschenhand geschaffenes Artefakt
wie einen Tisch, also gibt es mehrere Arten
von Fragen, die Sie über den Tisch stellen können, so
wie Sie es sind  Ich werde fragen, wer es gemacht hat, das
wäre der Handwerker, der Zimmermann. Sie
können fragen, warum es im Sinne von
wie für welchen Zweck gemacht wurde, also
vielleicht wurde es
zum Beispiel zum Essen gemacht, aber dann
gibt es noch zwei andere Arten  von qu
Fragen, die Sie stellen können, eine Frage, die Sie stellen können, ist,
woraus er besteht, und das wird die
Materie sein. Nehmen wir also an, es ist ein Holztisch,
also wäre die Materie Holz, und die
andere Frage ist, wie er ist,
wie seine Form ist  was bestimmt, dass
das Holz ein Tisch ist, und das wäre
die Form, so grob gesagt, die
Form des Tisches
, tatsächlich verwendet er manchmal ein Wort, das
mehr falsch ist, da ich eine Art Synonym für das
Wort Form bin,
also dasselbe, was er denkt  Das
gilt für Tiere. Wenn Sie sich
also ein Tierbaby vorstellen, das
im Schoß seiner Mutter liegt, nehmen wir
das Beispiel einer Giraffe, die Giraffe
wird aus irgendeinem
Material bestehen und braucht eine Form
auferlegt, die bestimmt, dass dieses
Material eine Giraffe ist und nicht ein
Gorilla oder ein Lama oder ein Fuchs oder ein Mensch oder
irgendein anderes Tier, und was Aristoteles
denkt, ist grob gesagt, dass das
Blut das Menstruationsblut in der Mutter
ist, was dann ist  gehen zu
erhalten  Die Form, die
durch sexuelle
Fortpflanzung aus dem Samen des Vaters in dieses Blut übertragen
wird, ist also im Grunde die Idee, dass die
Frau die Art von passiver
rezeptiver Zutat für die Erzeugung bereitstellt und
der Mann oder das männliche Tier
die aktive Form bereitstellt  bestimmende
Zutat der Generation, also wäre es wieder so
, als ob Tiere
Tische wären, dann liefert die Frau die
Materie, aus der sie gemacht sind, und der Mann ist wie
der Zimmermann, der die Form auf
das Holz bringt, indem er das Holz entsprechend schneidet und anordnet
, um a zu sein
Das ist eine Sache, die er über
die Tiererzeugung denkt, die wichtig ist, eine andere Sache, die Sie über die Tiererzeugung denken
, die wichtig ist, ist,
dass es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen der
Art und Weise, wie Weibchen und
Männchen erzeugt werden, also werden Weibchen
als Ergebnis eines Defekts erzeugt
im generativen Prozess und das ist so
viele NSAIDs und Generation von Tieren in
diesem Fall Buch für Kap  ter 6 also
Idee hier scheint besorgt zu sein über diese
Blutmischung im Mutterleib
des weiblichen Tieres der Eltern der
Mutter und wenn alles gut geht, ist das
anscheinend so, als ob es
genug Hitze gibt, man bekommt ein junges Tier, aber
wenn die Hitze  ist ein bisschen reduziert,
dann bekommt man ein weibliches Tier, das ist
eigentlich etwas seltsam, weil es so klingt,
als ob Aristoteles sagen würde, dass weibliche
Tiere nur defekt sind, jetzt Tiere,
als wäre etwas ein bisschen schief gelaufen,
und so bekommt man ein weibliches Tier hinein
ein männliches Tier und nur er kann sich
denken, dass ich meine, das wäre wirklich
seltsam, weil danke sagen würde
, dass die Hälfte aller Tiere
defekt sind und die weiblichen und nicht
nur das, aber natürlich
funktioniert die natürliche Fortpflanzung nur, wenn
Sie es haben  weibliche Tiere richtig ich meine wenn
sozusagen in jeder Generation einer
Giraffe alles so gut wie möglich gelaufen ist also die Hitze immer abgetippt
wurde dann bekommt man nur noch eine Sache Flöße und
das wäre  bedeutet, dass es, sobald Sie
zur nächsten Generation kommen, überhaupt keine Giraffen mehr geben würde,
weil Sie keine
Weibchen hätten, mit denen sie sich fortpflanzen
könnten, also könnten Sie das denken,
aber ich denke, ich sage immer noch, dass er seine
Vorstellung davon hat, wo Weibchen sind  Tiere kommen
aus dieser Art der
Erklärung für unzureichende Hitze und im
Allgemeinen wird es eine sehr lange
Tradition des Denkens in diesen Begriffen geben, also
diese Art der physikalischen Erklärung dafür, wie sich
Frauen von Männern unterscheiden und wie sich weibliche
Tiere von heutigen Tieren im
Allgemeinen unterscheiden  es ist sehr üblich, sie
Dinge sagen zu sehen wie Frauen sind kälter,
sie sind feuchter und sie meinen nicht
kälter, sondern emotional, sie meinen
körperlich kälter. Ich frage mich manchmal,
ob sie die Beobachtung gemacht haben, dass
die Hände von Frauen tendenziell kälter sind als die von
Männern  Ich denke, das ist vielleicht
wahr, aber aus welchem Grund auch immer, ob es auf e
hten Beob
chtungen beruhen soll oder nicht, sie denken, dass sich Frauenkörp
r von unseren Körpern un
erscheiden  Es und auf diese sehr spezifische Weise,
dass sie
weniger Hitze haben und Sahara Solo sagt,
dass dies bereits auf der Stufe der
Generation des Tieres und der Mutter zutrifft, ok, ein
weiteres Prinzip, das er in
der Zoologie beobachtet, das
weniger gut zu dem passt, was wir haben  Bisher wurde gesagt,
dass Kinder sowohl ihren Müttern als
auch ihren Vätern ähneln, und das ist
übrigens offensichtlich wahr, und tatsächlich ist es
wahrer, als Sie vielleicht denken,
also haben sie Studien darüber durchgeführt, ob
Kinder ihren Vätern ähneln oder ihre
Mütter zu Aerosolen werden  Ich
meine, die Leute haben kürzlich 10 Studien gemacht
und man kann tatsächlich zeigen, dass die Leute
erkennen können, dass
sie Mütter und Väter von Kindern nicht erkennen können,
indem sie sich ein Bild von einem Kind und
dann oder eine Reihe von Bildern von
Müttern und Vätern ansehen
Interessanterweise sind die Leute jedoch besser
darin, die Väter und die Mütter
auszuwählen, also scheint es wahr zu sein, wenn dies richtig ist, also habe ich ein wenig darüber nachgelesen und was auch immer ich gelesen habe, war das  Tatsächlich
ähneln Menschen statistisch gesehen
häufiger ihren Vätern als ihren Müttern,
was eine evolutionäre Grundlage haben könnte, da
die Mutter weiß, dass es ihr Kind ist,
aber der Vater nicht weiß, ob es sein
Kind ist, und daher ist es eigentlich ziemlich nützlich
, wie dein Vater auszusehen oder so
auszusehen  Ihrer Mutter hilft es nicht wirklich,
aber es ist offensichtlich, dass Dinge wie
Haarfarbe, Augenfarbe,
Nasenform usw. von beiden Elternteilen vererbt werden können,
und jeder kennt diesen
Aristoteles damit, und Sie denken vielleicht,
ok, also was für eine große Sache, aber denken Sie daran  zu dem, was
ich vorher darüber gesagt habe, was die Welt der Mutter
in der Generation ist, das Muttertier
ist da, um die Materie bereitzustellen,
der Vater stellt die Form bereit, und Sie
würden denken, dass Dinge wie Haarfarbe
okay, ich bin ein schlechtes Beispiel, oder sie haben jede
Haarfarbe, aber  Eine andere Farbe meines Auges
ist die Form meiner Nase und so weiter, du
würdest denken, dass diese Glocke wie meine Form klingt, nicht wie
meine Sache, also eigentlich, wenn du
tief in seine neue Logik eintauchst und
Wenn man genauer darüber nachdenkt
und einige der Gelehrten dies getan haben
, erkennt man, dass er tatsächlich eine Art Sprudelmechanismus hervorrufen muss,
wodurch die Frau oder das
weibliche Tier im Allgemeinen
einige ihrer Eigenschaften an die Nachkommen weitergeben kann, genau
wie das Männchen  tut, und so kann es sein, dass
das Menstruationsblut nicht
nur als eine Art
homogenes Zeug aufgefasst werden sollte, das bei
jedem einzelnen Mitglied einer Art gleich ist,
sondern das Menstruationsblut kann
eine Art von Prädispositionen enthalten, die
sich in der Generation herausbilden  von jedem Tier
okay, das ist also, was er über Zoologie zu sagen hat,
wenden wir uns nicht dem zu, was er
in Ethik und Politik sagt, und wie
ich gewarnt habe, kann das, was er in Ethik und Politik sagt, bei
weitem nicht
der Vorstellungskraft entsprechen  Feministinnen hält er es
einfach für selbstverständlich,
dass Frauen Männern unterlegen sind, und hier sollte
man natürlich bedenken, dass
er, wenn er über Frauen spricht, oft
nur nebenbei spricht und normalerweise versucht,
etwas anderes zu machen  Also, er importiert diese Idee
über die blühende Unterlegenheit von Frauen
einfach als eine Art gesunden Menschenverstand
, den fast jeder teilt, und
zieht dann die Konsequenzen für ein anderes
Thema, über das er spricht,
und ein großartiges Beispiel dafür ist a  Eine berühmte
Passage in seiner Ethik, die ich aufstellen
werde und die er für Sie tun wird, also sind wir hier in
Medina von Mekka, betrifft sowohl das achte Kapitel
als auch das siebte Kapitel, und er spricht über Freundschaft, er
spricht über die verschiedenen Arten von
Freundschaft, und er sagt, aber es gibt noch eine
andere  Art von Freundschaft, die
eine Ungleichheit zwischen den
Parteien beinhaltet, lassen Sie zum Beispiel einen Vater-zu-Sohn
und im Allgemeinen von Elder T den jüngeren, den
Mann zur Frau und im Allgemeinen den vom Herrscher
zum Untertanen, und diese Freundschaften unterscheiden sich
auch voneinander, weil es so ist  nicht das
gleiche, was zwischen Eltern und
Kindern und zwischen Herrschern und Untertanen besteht,
noch ist ein Vater-zu-Sohn das
gleiche wie das eines Vaters, noch dass ein
Mann zu einer Frau dasselbe ist wie das von einer Frau
zu einem Mann  In allen Freundschaften, die Ungleichheit implizieren,
sollte die Liebe auch
proportional sein, je besser die Liebe sein sollte,
als er liebt, und
desto nützlicher und ähnlich in jedem der
anderen Fälle, wenn die Liebe im
Verhältnis
zum Verdienst der Parteien steht  Es
entsteht ein Gefühl der Gleichheit, das
sicherlich als charakteristisch für Freundschaft angesehen wird.
Okay, was es hier sagt, der
Kontext ist, dass er erklärt hat,
dass perfekte Freundschaften
Gleichheit zwischen den beiden Freunden haben, also wäre für
ihn eine perfekte Freundschaft eine
Freundschaft zwischen zwei  Menschen, die
beide tugendhaft sind, die
die Tugend des
anderen bewundern und einander die Tugend im Freund widerspiegeln,
gibt es auch andere Arten von
Freundschaften, die fehlerhafter sind, also
wäre ein Beispiel ein Freund, mit dem Sie
einfach nur gerne Zeit verbringen, aber Sie
Werten Sie diesen Charakter nicht wirklich
, Sie könnten sogar denken, dass
Ihr Freund in gewisser Weise ein kompletter Idiot ist, aber
es ist großartig, etwas zu trinken  Mit diesem
Freund zu arbeiten, weil der Freund zum Beispiel so viel Spaß macht
oder der Freund für Sie nützlich ist, als
wären Sie vielleicht Geschäftspartner,
also bewundern Sie sich nicht unbedingt
gegenseitig für Ihren tugendhaften Charakter,
aber Sie verdienen viel Geld
zusammen, also deine freunde in diesem sinne
das sind die defekten freundschaften die
perfekte freundschaft wäre eine charakterfreundschaft
die tugendfreundschaft wo
du wieder zwei männer hast so gut wie du
weißt wahrscheinlich an männer denken oder
von männern an männer weitergeben die sowohl
tugendhaft als auch gütig sind  zusammenzuarbeiten und
tugendhaft zu sein, also spricht er jetzt
über ungleiche Beziehungen und
gibt Ihnen eine Reihe von Beispielen, zum
Beispiel Eltern und Kind, also geht man einfach
davon aus, dass die Eltern als reifer
Erwachsener dem Kind überlegen und besser sind als
sie  Sie sind ungleich, denkt, das ist
offensichtlich, aber er denkt, es
gibt eine Art
Freundschaftsbeziehung, das griechische Wort ist Vidya,
also könnten Sie vielleicht darüber reden, dass sie es
waren  Übersetzt sowohl als Zuneigung als auch als
Freundschaft, gibt es eine Zuneigung zwischen
den Eltern und dem Kind, obwohl
sie ungleich sind, und jetzt gibt er ein weiteres
Beispiel für Männer und Frauen, also ist sein Gedanke
hier, dass, obwohl die Frau in einer
Ehe dem Mann unterlegen ist
Ehemann hat immer noch Zuneigung zu ihr und
umgekehrt, also ist es möglich, dass
es Freundschaft zwischen
ungleichen Parteien gibt. Der Ehemann und die Ehefrau sind
ein Beispiel dafür, aber das ist keine
perfekte Freundschaft, und beachten Sie, dass er
auch die
Zuneigung des Mannes anzudeuten scheint  Die Zuneigung für die
Frau sollte geringer sein als die
Zuneigung der Frau für den Mann, weil
sie schlechter ist als er, und die
Liebe sollte dem Wert dessen entsprechen
, was geliebt wird, so wie Sie eine
tugendhafte Person mehr schätzen als eine weniger
tugendhafte  Person, also der Wert des Mannes in
Bezug darauf, wertvoller zu sein und
sich idealerweise in der Art und Weise
widerzuspiegeln, wie alle füreinander empfinden,
also ist das ein gutes Beispiel für eine Art von
Eine deprimierende Passage, in der unser
Subtiler die Minderwertigkeit von Frauen für selbstverständlich hält,
wäre ein weiteres gutes Beispiel dafür
, wenn er in der Ethik über
die Beziehung zwischen Menschen spricht, als ob
es eine Art politische Beziehung wäre,
gibt es einen anderen Text, der wiederum aus
den Büchern über Freundschaft stammt  also sind wir immer noch
hier in Buch acht, jetzt gehen wir zu
Kapitel zehn und er spricht über die
Art und Weise, wie politische Vereinbarungen eine
Art Parallele im Kontext des
Haushalts darstellen
, wenn sie Ähnlichkeiten mit
der Verfassung finden, mit anderen Worten,
Wege  Organisation eines politischen Staates
sozusagen Muster davon sogar in Haushalten
für die Vereinigung eines Vaters mit seinen
Söhnen
gibt es die Form der Monarchie, da der
Vater für seine Kinder sorgt und
deshalb Homer bewirkt, dass der Vater es ist das
Ideal der Monarchie, väterlich zu sein  aber
bei den Persern ist die Herrschaft des
Vaters zu radikal, sie gerade ihre
Söhne als Sklaven
zu radikal, um die Herrschaft eines Herrn
über Sklaven zu sein  r ist der Vorteil des
Meisters, der darin zustande kommt, dass die
Verbindung von Mann und Frau
aristokratisch erscheint, denn der Mann regiert
gemäß seinem Wert und in jenen
Angelegenheiten, in denen ein Mann regieren sollte, aber
die Angelegenheiten, die das Schicksal der Frau betreffen  Er
übergibt ihr, wenn der Mann in
allem war, die Beziehung geht in die
Oligarchie über,
denn dabei handelt er nicht
nach ihrem jeweiligen Wert
und regiert nicht aufgrund seiner
Überlegenheit. Manchmal regieren jedoch Frauen,
weil sie Eris gehören
, also war das Noggin  Für wahre Exzellenz
Purdue – Reichtum und Macht als
Oligarchie, also sagt er,
dass es verschiedene Wege gibt,
eine Gesellschaft zu führen, und einer der Wege ist wie in einer
Monarchie, also kann man entweder und anderswo,
wie in seiner Politik, sagt er, dass es
anders ist  Arten von Staaten können degradieren, indem
sie korrupt werden, und wenn eine Monarchie
degradiert, verwandelt sie sich in eine Tyrannei, so dass für
ihn eine Monarchie eine
Monarchie wäre, in der angemessen gesprochen die Monarchie wäre  der
König seine Herrschaft hat absolute Herrschaft, aber
seine Herrschaft zum Wohle der
Untertanen ein Tyrann ist jemand, der die
gleiche Art von Herrschaft hat, aber zu seinem eigenen
Vorteil regiert, und Aristoteles macht hier eine Pause, um zu sagen,
oh, das ist genau wie die
Beziehung zwischen Herr und Sklave  oder
in Persien die Beziehung zwischen
Vätern und Söhnen, weil sie versucht haben, dass
der Herr nur auf seinen eigenen Vorteil schaut,
er kümmert sich nicht um
den Nutzen des Sklaven, was
eigentlich eine scharfe und wahre
Beobachtung über Sklaverei zu sein scheint, und dann
interessanterweise er  sagt, dass die Beziehung
zwischen dem Mann und der Frau in einer
Ehe aristokratisch sein sollte, und was
er damit meint, ist, dass eine
Aristokratie eine ist, in der die bessere Klasse
über die anderen herrscht, aber auch hier
suchen sie den Nutzen
aller  Die Gesellschaft ist nicht nur ihr eigener Vorteil,
wenn Sie, wenn die bessere Klasse die reichere
Klasse zu ihrem eigenen Vorteil sieht, dann
verwandelt sie sich in eine Oligarchie, also ist das
wieder interessant, er.  s setzt die
Unterlegenheit der Frau voraus, aber er
sagt zumindest, dass der Mann über die Frau herrschen sollte,
als ob sie eine Sklavin wäre, oder
sie nur als Werkzeug oder Instrument für
seine eigenen Zwecke benutzt, anstatt die Maske, nicht
die Maske, die dem Ehemann angepaßt werden sollte
Herrschen über die Frau, indem sie sie gewissermaßen
lenken und die Show leiten, aber im Hinblick
auf ihre beiderseitigen Interessen,
tatsächlich die Interessen des gesamten Haushalts,
und dies ist genauso wie in einer Aristokratie
im Gegensatz zu einer Oligarchie die
Oberschicht regiert  im Hinblick auf das
Wohl der ganzen Gesellschaft so
offensichtlich mit dieser
Ethik in gewisser Weise
bereits über Haushalte nachgedacht haben, über Politik nachgedacht haben,
und so ist es nicht
verwunderlich zu sehen, dass die gleichen
Ideen in seiner Politik auftauchen, sagen wir, es
gibt noch andere Passagen  von seiner
Politik ist dies aus Buch eins, wo
er Haushaltsführung oder Ökonomie berührt hat,
und er sagt über
Haushaltsführung, dass wir gesehen haben, dass es
drei Teile gibt, einer ist die Regel o  Ein Herr
über Sklaven, der bereits besprochen wurde, ein
anderer eines Vaters und der
dritte eines Ehemanns, eines Ehemanns und eines Vaters,
wir sahen Regeln für Ehefrau und Kinder,
beide frei, aber die Regel unterscheidet sich von der Regel, dass
seine Kinder königlich über
seine Frau sind, eine Verfassung
Dasselbe gilt also für die vorhergehende
Passage Monarchie und Adel, denn
obwohl es Ausnahmen von der Naturordnung geben mag, ist
das Männchen von Natur aus
Feder für das Kommando und das Weibchen ebenso wie
der Ältere in vollem Umfang
dem Jüngeren überlegen und  reifer,
aber in den meisten Rechtsstaaten
herrschen die Bürger und werden von Begriffen beherrscht, denn
die Idee eines Rechtsstaates
impliziert, dass die Wesen der Bürger
gleich sind und sich überhaupt nicht unterscheiden, dass das
Verhältnis des Mannes zur Frau von
dieser Art ist, dass dort  Die Ungleichheit ist
dauerhaft, also sagt er hier,
dass die Beziehung zwischen dem Mann
und der Frau im Haushalt
die bereits erwähnte Ungleichheit widerspiegeln
muss  In der Ethik sind Männer besser
als Frauen und sollten daher
immer das Sagen haben, aber sie sollten
auf das Wohl des gesamten Haushalts achten,
und das würde auch das Wohl
der Frau einschließen, also ist es wieder wirklich klar, dass
er es nicht tut  denken, dass Frauen
Sklaven von Männern sein sollten, denkt er, dass
sie Partner, aber ungleiche Partner sein sollten,
und das passt sehr gut zu der
Idee, dass die Frau eine wertvolle Rolle
im Haushalt zu spielen hat, aber eine spezifische
Rolle, die ihrem Geschlecht angemessen ist
nämlich den Haushalt zu führen, während der
Mann gehobenere Berufe ausübt,
vielleicht sollte er das Geld für
den Haushalt verdienen, und ich denke, das setzt auch
voraus, dass er in
der Lage wäre, noch mehr Dinge zu tun,
wie Philosophie und  Tatsächlich
schlägt er nie vor, dass Frauen
Philosophen sein sollten oder Philosophie betreiben können, wie es
Platon tut. Warum
gibt er uns also irgendeine
Erklärung für die Minderwertigkeit von
Frauen?  Ethik und
Politik Kommen wir gleich zu der
Frage, ob das, was wir gesehen haben,
unlogisch funktioniert, könnte erklären, was er
hier in der Ethik und Politik über Frauen sagt,
aber zuerst schauen wir uns die
berühmteste Passage aus der Politik
über Frauen an, weil es die ist  Am nächsten kommen
wir einer Erklärung der untergeordneten oder
untergeordneten Rolle der Frau im
Haushalt, also sagt er hier, dass fast
alle Dinge in unserer Welt
der Natur gemäß regieren, aber die Art der Herrschaft unterscheidet sich davon, dass
der freie Mann über den Sklaven herrscht
in dem der
Mann mit einem Mann über das Kind über die Frau geht,
obwohl die
Seelenanteile in allen vorhanden sind, sind sie
in unterschiedlichem Maße vorhanden, denn der Sklave hat überhaupt
keine Entscheidungsfähigkeit, die Frau
hat aber keine Autorität und die
Kind hat, aber es ist unreif, also muss es
unbedingt mit den
moralischen Richards auch an ihnen teilnehmen,
aber nur so und so, wie
es von jedem für erforderlich ist  die
Erfüllung seiner Pflicht,
daher sollte der Herrscher moralische
Tugend und Perfektion für seine Funktion haben,
die absolut verlangt, und ein Meister des
Handwerks und des rationalen Prinzips ist ein solcher
Handwerker, die Untertanen hingegen benötigen nur das Maß an Tugend,
das jedem von ihnen zusteht  eindeutig
und moralische Tugend gehört ihnen allen,
aber die Mäßigkeit eines Mannes und einer Frau
über den Mut und die Gerechtigkeit eines Mannes
und einer Frau sind nicht
dasselbe, wie Sokrates behauptete, der Mut eines Mannes
zeigt sich darin, eine Frau zu befehlen und
Ich möchte Sie darauf
hinweisen, dass ganz am Ende dieser
Passage der wahrscheinlich
aufregendere und interessantere Teil der
erste Teil ganz am Ende ist, den ich einfügen wollte,
weil es wie eine Anspielung
auf diese Passage war  Wir haben von Platon gesehen, wir
wissen, wo
Meno gut die Tugend eines Mannes und einer
Frau und eines Pferdes usw. sagt, sie waren
alle unterschiedlich, also müssen wir eine
Art unterschiedliche Charakterisierung der Tugend
geben  jeden Fall und so bin ich Penny sagt nein nein
nein Ich möchte, dass du mir sagst, was Tugend
im Allgemeinen ist, und er war es, sag das
gleiche für jeden
visuellen, praktisch maßgeschneiderten Mut, Gerechtigkeit,
Mäßigung und so weiter, du würdest eine
Art Fang wollen-  Alle Definitionen,
die Mut, Gerechtigkeit und Mäßigkeit
in jedem
Penny-Aerosol erklären, sagen jemals, nein, das ist falsch,
das können Sie nicht tun
Angesichts dessen, dass Frauen nicht
in den Krieg ziehen und kämpfen, wenn sie überhaupt Quark
haben, müssen sie in einem anderen Sinne Mut haben,
aber der Teil der Passage, der
mehr Aufmerksamkeit und Diskussion auf sich gezogen hat,
ist natürlich der Teil über Sklavinnen
und Kinder  Was er dort sagt, ist,
dass Menschen, die von Natur aus sklavisch sind,
und hier gibt es eine horizontale Theorie
über Sklaverei, und Aristoteles, auf die
wir nicht eingehen werden,
denkt im Grunde, dass Sklaven Menschen sind, die von
Natur aus ausschließlich sind  irrational oder so schwach
in ihrer rationalen Fähigkeit, dass sie
nicht wirklich ihre eigenen Angelegenheiten regeln
und Entscheidungen für sich selbst treffen können, also ist es
eigentlich ziemlich gut für sie, einen
Meister zu haben, der sie auf dem rechten
Weg hält und ihnen die besten Chancen auf
Führung gibt  das beste Leben, das sie leben können,
was natürlich nicht sehr gut ist, also
ist das alles offensichtlich entsetzlich usw.
wäre viel über Sklaverei zu sagen,
vielleicht ist das einzig Relevante, was Sie
hier sagen müssen, dass er versucht,
über Sklaverei zu berichten  erklärt das
Phänomen, also versucht er nicht,
das Phänomen zu kritisieren, genauso wenig wie er
Pratik die Art und Weise zuschreibt, wie Frauen
behandelt
werden  Also hält er es für
falsch, Menschen zu versklaven, die nicht von
Natur aus sklavisch sind, das sind keine sehr
tröstlichen Worte, vielleicht ein bisschen
tröstlich, und tatsächlich, wenn Sie dann sagen,
dass es tatsächlich Aerosol gibt, gibt es guten
Grund zum Nachdenken  dass niemand von Natur aus
sklavisch ist und wenn Sie ihn davon überzeugen könnten
, würde er in diesem Fall tatsächlich sagen,
dass wir keine Sklaverei haben sollten, aber er
sagt das nicht, also was ist mit den Frauen?
Nun, die Frauen haben eine sogenannte
deliberative Fähigkeit  Dass das Lexikon, also
die Fakultät, rationale Entscheidungen
darüber zu treffen, was zu tun ist, und dass sie
die richtige Entscheidung treffen, aber ihre Fakultät ist
schwächer oder ohne Autorität, es ist umständlich
in der griechischen Ordnung, also was
bedeutet das gut, es ist nicht ganz klar,
aber zumindest was auch immer so  Er sagt,
dass Frauen weniger in der Lage sind, gute Entscheidungen zu treffen
als Männer, und eine große
Frage hier ist, warum er der Meinung ist,
dass Gelehrte hier eine Versuchung
hatten, auf diese unlogischen
Werke zurückzublicken, also denken Sie darüber nach, was wir
dort die Frau gesehen haben  ist nur die Quelle der
Materie in Ordnung, aber sie wird auch durch ein
geringeres Maß an Wärme in der Schwangerschaft produziert, also ist es
vielleicht buchstäblich die physische
Verfassung ihres Körpers, die es
ihr unmöglich macht, vernünftig zu denken  wie
ein mann so machen kann das ist eine idee
diese ideen sind auch kritisiert und
hinterfragt worden mit der begründung das es im
grunde einfach keinen sinn macht wenn
man sich seine begründungstheorie
so anschaut und das ist eine sehr gute
art  Wiederholen Sie diese Theorie. Aristoteles
glaubt, dass Sie bei richtiger
intellektueller Aktivität tatsächlich
eine Fähigkeit verwenden, die kein körperliches Organ
hat. Denken ist also ein rein materieller
Prozess, der nicht von
Ihrem Gehirn ausgeführt wird, sondern von irgendeinem
physischen Organ ausgeführt wird  Wenn das stimmt, ist
es schwer zu verstehen, warum Frauen
zum Beispiel beim abstrakten Denken schlechter dran sein sollten
als Männer, insbesondere ist es schwer
zu verstehen, was Frauen nicht
genauso gut wie Männer philosophieren könnten, weil ihr
Körper nicht an der Philosophie
beteiligt ist  nicht etwas, was Sie
mit Ihrem Körper tun, die einzige Möglichkeit, es zu erklären
, könnte sein, dass, wenn der Körper der
Frauen kälter und feuchter ist und
so weiter, sie irgendwie eine weniger
gute Grundlage für den Tiefpunkt bieten können  Unsere psychologischen
Fähigkeiten, die dazu beitragen,
rationale Überlegungen und Philosophie
hervorzubringen, so wie es vielleicht Empfindungen gibt, die so
gut sind, funktionieren ihre Vorstellungskraft nicht
so gut, aber es ist tatsächlich ziemlich schwer
, nach aristotelischen Prinzipien zu erklären
, warum der weibliche Körper die Führung übernehmen sollte
zu dieser angeblich schwächeren Fähigkeit zu
argumentieren, und tatsächlich denke ich, dass es
fair wäre zu sagen, dass Aristoteles
dies
sorgfältiger durchdacht und weniger bereit gewesen wäre, sich
einfach mit dem Strom
der allgemeinen Überzeugungen der Menschen über Frauen zu
treiben, die er selbst haben könnte  gesehen, dass seine eigene
Philosophie ihm Gründe gab,
dieser Annahme, dass Frauen
Männern unterlegen sind, insbesondere in der
Hinsicht, dass er nämlich ihre rationalen Fähigkeiten erwähnt, zu skeptisch gegenüberstehen,
denn ich denke,
es gibt tatsächlich gute Gründe
zu der Annahme, dass seine Zoologie keine
liefert  gute Erklärung dafür, warum
Frauen Männern in dieser Hinsicht unterlegen sind,
obwohl sie Männern angeblich unterlegen sind
in anderer Hinsicht wie ein
bisschen kälter zu sein, okay, das
wollte ich über Aristoteles sagen. Lassen Sie uns jetzt
zu Plato übergehen, und das Offensichtliche,
worüber wir hier sprechen müssen, ist die Republik,
die diese ziemlich lange Passage über
Frauen und das, was sie sind, enthält  in der Gesellschaft tun können und nicht können,
und diese Passage ist aufregend, und
wir werden darüber sprechen, aber zuerst
wollte ich nur erwähnen, dass es nicht so ist, als
ob Plato eine Art Feministin der 1970er Jahre
wäre, die eine Zeitreise zurück ins antike
Griechenland und darüber hinaus gemacht hat  Tatsächlich gibt es
viele Passagen, in denen Plato ziemlich
böse Dinge über Frauen sagt. Ich glaube nicht, dass
diejenige, die wir uns gerade aus
dem Meno angesehen haben, unbedingt ein gutes Beispiel ist,
weil diese Passage eindeutig keine ist,
in der der Sprecher jemand ist, der verwendet wird
wir sollten glauben oder ernst nehmen, also stellt
Sokrates, wie gesagt, nicht in Frage,
was er über Frauen sagt, aber das
bedeutet nicht, dass wir dem zustimmen sollten,
was er über Frauen sagt,
im Gegensatz dazu gibt es einen anderen Dialog,
der besteht  Hauptsächlich von einer Rede eines
Philosophen namens Timaeus, die
auch vom Diät-Timaeus übrig blieb,
wo es so aussieht, als wäre der
Sprecher wahrscheinlich eine Art Sprecher von
Platons eigenen Überzeugungen über Gott, wie
Gott das Universum gestaltet hat, so dass dies jedoch wirklich
auf Platons Abhandlung über Kosmologie
steht  Sie sagen, es heißt Timäus,
und darin bekommen wir eine Erklärung, woher
die Welt kam, wie die Welt
organisiert ist, wie der Himmel funktioniert und auch,
wie die menschliche Anatomie strukturiert ist, und dann
kommt er irgendwann dazu, darüber zu sprechen,
woher die Tiere kamen  warum haben
wir also nicht nur den kosmos und den menschen,
sondern auch andere tiere, dann kommt er
irgendwann auch auf pflanzen zu sprechen und
wenn er über tiere spricht,
macht er damit sehr deutlich, dass er denkt, dass
es in der natur eine art rangordnung der
qualität gibt  wo man
an der Spitze menschliche Männer hat, dann menschliche Frauen und dann
Tiere, und das wird am fairsten, wenn
er über Reinkarnation spricht, weil
er glaubt, dass unsere Seelen handeln können
Verbündeten von einem Körper zum anderen gehen und sie können
sogar von menschlichen Körpern in nichtmenschliche
Körper übergehen, also lasst uns einen Blick darauf werfen, was er
darüber sagt, also ist dies der
wegabhängige Emmaus, den er, der
während seiner bestimmten Zeit gut lebte, zurückkehren sollte
und  in seinem Heimatstern und seinem
Volk verweilen, um ein gesegnetes und sympathisches
Dasein zu haben, aber wenn er
dies bei der zweiten Geburt nicht erreichen würde, würde er
in eine Frau übergehen, und wenn er in diesem Zustand
des Seins nicht vom Bösen ablassen
würde, würde er ständig verändert werden  in eine
Frucht, mit anderen Worten, ein Tier,
das ihm in der bösen Natur ähnelte, die
er erworben hatte, und später in einem
Dialog sagt er, dass eine kurze Erwähnung
der Generation anderer Tiere gemacht werden kann, also
anderer Tiere als Menschen der Menschen,
die in die kamen  Welt, die
Feiglinge waren oder ein ungerechtes Leben führten, können
mit Recht angenommen werden, dass sie sich
in der zweiten Generation in die Natur der Frau
verwandelt haben, und dies war der Grund, warum
die Götter damals in uns das
Verlangen schufen  des Geschlechtsverkehrs erfinden
ein Mann eine belebte Substanz und eine
Frau und andere, so wurden Frauen geschaffen
und das weibliche Geschlecht im Allgemeinen, aber das
Geschlecht der Vögel wurde aus
unschuldigen gleichgesinnten Männern geschaffen, die sich vorstellen werden,
dass ihre Gedanken
auf den Himmel gerichtet waren  In ihrer
Einfachheit, dass die klarste
Demonstration der oben genannten Dinge
durch Sehen zu erreichen war, wurden
diese umgebaut und
in Vögel verwandelt, und ihnen wuchsen Federn
anstelle von Haaren. Der Grund, warum ich
diesen letzten Teil über Vögel aufgenommen habe, ist, Ihnen zu zeigen
, dass er tatsächlich denkt, dass ein Mensch
Ein Mann kann als viele
verschiedene Dinge wiedergeboren werden, und eines der Dinge, die
Sie wiedergeborene Eier sein können, von denen Sie
nicht wollen, dass sie unsere einheimischen Enden lesen,
ist eine Frau, also was ich meine, sind alle
technischen Details über Reinkarnation
und warum Plato daran glaubt  Es ist klar,
dass der Spieler in dieser Passage nur
davon ausgeht, dass Männer besser sind als Frauen,
und tatsächlich geht er immer noch davon aus, wie ich
zuvor in der berühmten Passage gesagt habe  ge über
Frauen in der Republik, also ein bisschen
Kontext darüber, was hier vor sich geht, die
Republik ist ein fantastisches Buch, das Sie
unbedingt lesen sollten, es ist ziemlich lang, aber
es lohnt sich, es ist wahrscheinlich Platons
größter Dialog, und darin versucht er zu
erklären, was es bedeutet  für ein
Individuum gerecht zu sein, so dass die Tugend der Gerechtigkeit,
indem er das Individuum mit der Gesellschaft vergleicht,
und er sagt, dass es genauso wie im
Individuum drei Aspekte
der Seele gibt, hauptsächlich das, was er Vernunft,
Geist und Appetit nennt, also wären diese
offensichtlich eine Pfeife  Der Grund dafür ist, dass Ihre
Fähigkeit, Geist zu besuchen, der
Teil Ihrer Seele ist, mit dem Sie Ärger empfinden
und auch nach Ehre verlangen, und dann ist
Appetit Ihr Wunsch nach Vergnügen, also haben Sie
diese drei Teile der Seele auf die
gleiche Weise, wie Sie eine dreiteilige Struktur haben
Gesellschaft, in der man oben Herrscher hat, von
denen er sagt, dass sie Philosophen sein müssen, in
der Mitte Soldaten, die
Wächter genannt werden, und unten
alle anderen, und er räumt das ein
sind sehr umstrittene Behauptungen,
besonders der Teil darüber, dass
Philosophen die Menschen sein müssen, die die
Gesellschaft regieren, aber wie ich bereits sagte, Plato ist
nur die Art von
Philosoph, der dies tut, er ist sehr
glücklich darüber, unsere gemeinsamen Überzeugungen darüber,
wie die Gesellschaft funktionieren sollte, zu revidieren  Eine
Art und Weise, wie er diese Überzeugungen revidiert, besteht darin, zu sagen,
dass Philosophen die besten
Herrscher sind, was er zugibt, dass jeder
denken wird, dass es absurd ist
Da die Art der
Meinung der Menschen darüber, wie die Gesellschaft
funktioniert, in Bezug auf Frauen
wieder so ist, hat er wirklich
betont, dass jeder denken wird,
dass dies lächerlich und unglaubwürdig ist,
aber es ist trotzdem wahr, und wie er sagt, sollten
wir das nicht.  Haben Sie keine Angst, unglaubwürdige Dinge zu sagen,
solange sie wahr sind, aus
Angst, ausgelacht zu werden. Was wir
jetzt tun möchten, ist, sich seine Gründe dafür anzusehen, warum er
denkt, dass Frauen alles tun können  g
, was Männer in der einfach perfekten Gesellschaft tun können,
und um dies zu erklären, zieht er einen
Vergleich zwischen dem Fall von Menschen
und dem Fall von Tieren, also wird
ein Tier ins Bild kommen,
also ist hier die Passage, die unsere Hunde
in Männer unterteilt haben  und weiblich oder teilen sie beide
gleichermaßen das Jagen und
Wachen und die anderen Ts von Hunden, so
dass Sokrates spricht und er
mit McCloud Conda spricht, der tatsächlich eine der
Hauptfiguren der Pilotenbrüder in der
Republik ist, also sagt Bachmann nein, er sagte,
sie teilen sich gleich  Der einzige Unterschied
zwischen ihnen ist, dass die Männchen
stärker und mit E-Mails schwächer sind. Entschuldigung,
sagt er, aber können Sie verschiedene Tiere
für denselben Zweck verwenden, es sei denn, sie werden
auf die gleiche Weise gezüchtet und gefüttert, können Sie dann nicht,
wenn Frauen die gleichen
Aufgaben haben sollen wie  Männer, sie müssen die
gleiche Erziehung haben, ja, die Ausbildung
wurde den Männern zugewiesen, war Musik im
Turnen, ja, dann müssen Frauen
Musik im Turnen und auch die Kunst des
Krieges lernen, die sie haben  wie ein Mann üben muss,
und dann sagt er weiter, dass sie, wenn
das alles wahr ist
, den ganzen Lehrplan anwenden müssen, der
bereits in der Republik beschrieben wurde, der verwendet wurde
, um gute Wächter zu Soldaten zu machen  in der
Gesellschaft werden einige von ihnen zu Philosophen,
wir müssen den Frauen
die gleichen
Gelegenheiten bieten wie den Männern, damit sie
die gleiche Menge Musik hören, sie
sollten der gleichen Art von Literatur ausgesetzt sein
und sie sollten das Gleiche tun  eine Art
Körpergymnastik, mit anderen Worten
Übungen und Sporttraining für den Krieg,
und eines der Dinge, die dazu gehören,
ist, dass das Training
ohne Kleidung durchgeführt werden sollte, und dies ist
eines der Dinge, die Sie vielleicht über das
antike Griechenland wissen  Die übliche
Praxis war, dass die sogenannte
Gymnastik nackt gemacht wurde,
eigentlich funktioniert das, und
Meister kommen davon, kommt vom
griechischen Wort für nackt, gute Nase,
jedenfalls sagt er, das ist s  Etwas, das die
Leute wirklich
lächerlich finden werden, dass Männer
und Frauen nackt zusammen
Sport treiben, und dann sagt er sogar, du weißt,
dass nicht nur die jungen, attraktiven
Leute das
tun werden, sondern auch die Alten  unattraktive Männer und
Frauen, und er gibt zu, dass jeder
denken wird, das sei Phosphor, aber er denkt immer noch,
dass es eine gute Idee ist, okay, also wird die
Ausbildung von Frauen die
gleiche sein wie die von Männern und sie
werden alle die gleichen Rollen übernehmen und dann  er sagt,
jemand könnte sich darüber beschweren
und sagen, dass die Natur der Frauen
anders ist als die der Männer, so dass
sie nicht in der Lage sind, diese
Pflichten in der Gesellschaft zu erfüllen, und er sagt,
dass das falsch ist, und seine eigenen Argumente dafür,
warum das falsch ist  Auf die Frage, ob Sie
irgendein Streben der Menschheit nennen können, bei dem
das männliche Geschlecht nicht alle diese Gaben und
Qualitäten in höherem Maße hat als der
weibliche Akt. Es ist Zeitverschwendung, über
die Kunst des Webens und die Verwaltung von
Panc zu sprechen  Schönheiten und Konserven, in denen
Frauen den
Griff der Haare nicht wirklich als großartig bezeichnen und in
denen sie ausgerechnet von einem Magneten
aufs Absurdeste geschlagen werden soll, haben
Sie mit der Aufrechterhaltung der
allgemeinen Unterlegenheit ganz recht  das weibliche Geschlecht,
obwohl viele Frauen vielen Männern zu viele Dinge
überlegen sind, ist doch im Großen
und Ganzen wahr, was Sie sagen, und Sokrates sagt
und sein so mein Freund, es gibt
in diesem Staat keine besondere Fakultät für Verwaltung,
die eine Frau hat, weil sie eine Frau ist
oder  die ein Mann aufgrund der Einschätzung hat,
aber die Gaben der Natur sind
sowohl in allen Beschäftigungen von
Männern als auch in allen Beschäftigungen von Frauen verbreitet, als dass
eine Frau Angst
vor einem Mann hat, so dass dies ziemlich seltsam aussehen kann
Eine Art feministisches Argument dafür, warum
Frauen alles können, was Männer können, also
scheint das Argument zwei Teile zu haben, ein
Teil ist ein Warten. Gibt es nicht einige Dinge
, in denen Frauen besser sind, wie
Essen backen und sich um den Haushalt kümmern, also die
Dinge  dass Har  ris auto wollte im Grunde, dass
Männer eine der Frauen tun und einen Dienst tun.
Ja, das sind Dinge, bei denen
Frauen besser sind als Männer, aber sie spielen keine
Rolle
, also ist das irrelevant, und
übrigens denken sie vielleicht auch, dass Männer es tun
würden  lernen, backen und nähen
und weben und so, vielleicht könnten sie das sowieso besser
als Frauen, aber es spielt keine
Rolle, denn das ist nicht das, worüber wir
reden, wir reden über die
wirklich wichtige Rolle, den
Staat zu führen, und  dafür gibt es naturgemäß keinen
unterschied zwischen mann und
frau, denn die
frau kann alles, was ein mann kann
, nur dass man es nicht so
gut kann und die frau sich
zum beispiel engagieren kann  diesen Staat regiert, und
Platon sagt auch ausdrücklich, dass einige
Frauen das haben, was er philosophische Naturen nennt, und Philosophen sein
können,
da Frauen diese Dinge tun können, wäre es
eigentlich unnatürlich, sie
daran zu hindern, also wäre es eine Art
Eine Verletzung ihrer Kapazitäten wäre eine
Verschwendung ihrer Fähigkeiten. Eine Verschwendung ihrer
Kapazitäten würde effektiv darin bestehen, einen
Haufen talentierter Bürger Ihrer
Gemeinde zu nehmen und sie ihre Talente nicht nutzen zu lassen,
was
dem Staat und der Natur sehr schaden würde, wie Platon
sagt  Okay, das ist das Argument,
deshalb werden wir weibliche Soldaten haben,
sie werden in Kriegszüge
gehen, sie werden in einigen Fällen
Philosophen werden, und diese Philosophensoldaten
werden die Stadt
zusammen mit den männlichen Philosophen so
ideal regieren  Acht könnte sich eine Situation vorstellen,
in der es einen ganzen Rat der
Philosophenkönige und Philosophenköniginnen gibt
oder das Laufen eine perfekte Gesellschaft
von oben ist, die allen anderen sagt, was
sie tun sollen, okay, also klingt das
auf eine Art feministisch und irgendwie
nicht so der feministische Teil  Wenn
wir alles können, was Männer können, ist der nicht-
feministische Teil offensichtlich, dass Frauen
Dinge nicht so gut können wie Männer,
und das ist wirklich interessant  Aufsatz
dazu von einer Philosophin oder Gelehrten der
antiken Philosophie namens Julia Anis, die
sagte, dies sei ein sehr gut getroffener
Punkt. Sie sagt, es sei kaum ein feministisches
Argument zu behaupten, dass Frauen
keine besondere Sphäre haben, weil Männer
sie absolut alles übertreffen können  und das
Beste daran ist eine Art allgemeineres Argument
, das sie dafür anführt, dass sie
Platons feministischen Ansprüchen so skeptisch gegenübersteht, und sie
macht hier eine Reihe von Punkten, also
kritisiert sie wirklich andere Autoren, die
ich spielen gesehen habe, es war eine Art Feministin
oder so  Proto-Feministin und einer der
offensichtlichsten Gründe, daran skeptisch zu sein,
ist genau, dass er nicht sagt,
dass Frauen Männern gleichgestellt sind, er sagt nur, dass
sie alles können, was wir können
, nur nicht so gut, also ist das eine
andere Sache  Das
ist aber ein wirklich guter Punkt, an dem sie sich
beschwert, dass Platon hier eigentlich nicht
von dem Wunsch motiviert ist,
Frauen eine Art vollständig verwirklichtes, vollständig
erfülltes Leben zu geben, in dem th  Sie können
all ihren Hoffnungen, Träumen und
Wünschen nachgehen, so dass sie sagt, dass das Argument
nicht auf den Wünschen oder Bedürfnissen von Frauen basiert und sich nicht darauf bezieht,
überhaupt nichts
darüber gesagt wird, ob die gegenwärtige
Rolle der Frau sie frustriert oder ob sie ein
befriedigenderes Leben führen wird  als
Wächter, als als hausgebundene Groll, also
als Julia und wir wieder,
und ich denke, sie hat Recht damit,
also sagt er nicht, dass wir Frauen Soldaten und Philosophen werden lassen sollten,
weil
einige Frauen Soldaten und
Philosophen sein wollen und sie sehr verärgert sein werden
oder ein weniger erfülltes Leben haben, wenn
sie dies nicht dürfen und
ihre natürlichen Fähigkeiten ausüben oder ihre natürlichen Fähigkeiten verwirklichen
,
darum geht es nicht, andererseits, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, deshalb denkt er auch nicht,
diese Soldaten und Philosophen
so zu führen  Sie wissen, dass er nicht der Meinung ist, dass der
Grund, warum ein philosophisch
begabter Mann ein Philosoph oder ein
Herrscher sein sollte, darin besteht, dass der Mann irgendwie von
anderen frustriert wäre  Wenn
wir über das Regieren sprechen, ist er sicherlich weise, er denkt sogar, dass
Männer, die Philosophen sind, wahrscheinlich
lieber nicht im Geschäft wären,
diese Gesellschaft zu regieren, weil sie lieber
ihre ganze Zeit damit verbringen würden, Philosophie zu betreiben, und
es gibt eine Passage an anderer Stelle in der
Republik oder bei Plato  sagt eigentlich, dass
wir
die begabten Philosophen davon überzeugen müssen
, den Staat zu regieren, weil
wir sie wirklich brauchen, also geht es
hier viel mehr darum,
Ressourcen effektiv zu nutzen, wie ich bereits sagte, bevor wir es
tun  Wir wollen Talente nicht verschwenden, wenn wir
sie in unserer Gesellschaft haben, und der Grund dafür
, Frauen zu erlauben, Soldaten und
Philosophen zu sein, ist, dass sie
manchmal Talente haben und es eine Verschwendung wäre, sie
nicht zu nutzen, aber eigentlich ist
das dasselbe  Der Grund, warum Männer
in unserer Gesellschaft auch Soldaten und Philosophen sein werden,
also vielleicht anders
ausgedrückt, ist Platon im Allgemeinen in der Republik
und insbesondere in dieser Passage über
Frauen
pas  er denkt nicht einmal an
die Interessen einzelner Frauen,
weil er nicht an die
Interessen einzelner Personen in der Republik
im Allgemeinen denkt, wenn er über den
einzelnen spricht, er spricht über ihn im Hinblick
auf die Balance zwischen einer angemessenen
Beziehung zwischen den drei Teilen
der Seele  das ich schon erwähnt habe und das
glücklich erfüllte gerechte Leben wird
jemand sein, dessen Seele in Harmonie ist, wenn er
über die Gesellschaft kommt, spricht er über das
Wohl des Stadtstaates oder das Wohl
der Gesellschaft und nicht über das Wohl
der Individuen, die darin leben  und das ist
er eigentlich ein bisschen anders als
Arizona, weil ein Harris alles zu glauben scheint,
dass die beste politische
Verfassung eine ist, die die
besten Chancen hat,
glückliche, erfüllte Menschen hervorzubringen. Im Gegensatz dazu
scheint bei Platon die Idee zu sein, dass
man glücklich sein kann  erfülltes Individuum,
nur weil es eine gute Seele hat, auch wenn Sie
in einem tyrannischen, schrecklichen Zustand leben, also ist
es nicht so sehr, was wir haben wollen
Philosophenherrscher, damit
jeder so erfüllt wie möglich sein kann. Tatsächlich werden die meisten
Menschen ein sehr gutes erfülltes
Leben haben, weil sie keine Soldaten oder
Philosophen sein werden, sondern Handwerker oder
Händler, die die unterste Klasse erheben, und
sein Interesse besteht nicht darin,
jeden Menschen zu verwirklichen  das Beste aus ihren
Fähigkeiten zu machen, um sie individuell glücklich zu machen,
sein Interesse besteht darin,
ihre Fähigkeiten zu verwirklichen, damit
der Staat gedeihen kann, wie ein allgemeines
Merkmal von Platons politischer Philosophie,
und es ist nicht nur etwas, das
für seine Behandlung von Frauen so relevant ist  Eine andere
Sache, die es wert wäre, hier gesagt zu werden, ist,
dass er, obwohl er zu glauben scheint, dass
alle Frauen Männern mit
der gleichen Natur oder der gleichen Art von
Fähigkeiten unterlegen sind, eindeutig auch denkt, dass einige
Frauen den meisten Männern weit überlegen sind,
weil, wenn wir  Es wird einige
philosophische Herrscher geben, die Frauen sind, sie sind
in der höchsten Klasse, sie sind die
talentiertesten, sie sind die mutigsten
die edelsten die intelligentesten und
sie werden daher als Menschen viel besser
sein als die überwiegende Mehrheit der
Menschen in der Gesellschaft, obwohl er
davon ausgeht, dass es selbstverständlich ist,
dass Frauen Männern unterlegen sein werden,
wenn Sie freundlich sind  von verglichen mögen zu
mögen Ich denke, aus dem,
was er hier sagt, geht auch ziemlich klar hervor, dass es
Frauen geben kann, die in so
ziemlich jeder Hinsicht besser sind als fast
alle Männer, also ist das UFO, das eine Feministin ist,
glaube ich nicht  zumindest nicht in
etwas wie dem Feminismus, wie wir ihn heute kennen,
weil die Motivationen so
unterschiedlich sind, aber es hat funktioniert, was es
zeigt, ist, dass seine Ansichten über Frauen
weit von den zeitgenössischen Ansichten über
Frauen entfernt waren, die viel näher an dem sind, was
wir sehen  in Aristoteles, und wenn wir weitergehen
und die Rezeption dieser Ich
ist sehen, werden wir feststellen, dass die Frauen, die
die Philosophen später
in der Antike treffen werden, die wir uns das nächste
Mal ansehen werden, eher in der einfachsten
Tradition stehen, nicht in der A  ristotelischen Tradition
und ich denke, es ist ziemlich offensichtlich, warum und
es ist auch offensichtlich, dass es
für das Mittelalter, das noch später besser aussehen wird, eine Schande ist,
dass Platons Gedanken
über Frauen in der Republik nicht
ins Lateinische übertragen wurden und nicht gelesen wurden
und wir nicht  Eine Hauptquelle des
Denkens über Frauen, das
von Philosophen im Mittelalter eher über Frauen
nachgedacht wurde, basiert hauptsächlich auf Aristoteles, und dies
ist eine Art trauriges oder sogar tragisches
Merkmal der Geschichte der Philosophie,
das die spätere Geschichte des Denkens
über Frauen im Allgemeinen war  viel stärker von
Aristoteles und Platon geprägt, aber die gute Nachricht ist,
dass Platon in der Spätantike immer noch eine
sehr wichtige Rolle dabei spielt,
die Erwartungen der Menschen darüber zu formen, was
Frauen tun können, und ein Ergebnis, wenn wir das nächste Mal
sehen werden, dass es eine Anzahl gab  von
Frauen, hauptsächlich in einer Art wahrscheinlich
polygamistischer philosophischer Perspektive
, die Philosophie betrieben und
interessante Dinge zu sagen hatten, also schließen Sie sich mir bitte als
nächstes an  Zeit